welcome back to the Ingram angle New
York's newest congresswoman socialist
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez is already
making waves on Capitol Hill in addition
to Medicare for all free college and her
plan to abolish ice the 29 year old now
says she wants to radically tax the rich
to pay for the left's environmental
agenda known as the Green Deal once you
get to like the tippy tops on your ten
millionth dollar
sometimes you see tax rates as high as
60 or 70% it doesn't mean all ten
million dollars are taxed at an
extremely high rate but it means that as
you climb up this ladder you should be
contributing more here now corey
lewandowski former Trump 2016 campaign
manager and co-authored the new book
Trump's enemies and no Mickey cones
she is a candidate for New York City
public advocate now before I get your
take both of you on this here are some
taxpayers reactions today watch the one
person does need to be taxed more than
they are but at the same time it Trump's
tax policy is helping the economy and
the economy is going well so I can't
really take a side on that yeah yeah I
think that's fair that's fair
I think that's percent seventy percent I
think it should be more than it is
so the 39% now right right top 1% That's
not me
I guess the shooter NASA Nancy Pelosi or
Bernie Sanders or the other one
percenters of her party what they think
now no Mickey is this a winning strategy
to tax upper income earners in this way
really yes
income inequality is worse than it's
ever been in America we're talking after
Wall Street crashed in 1929 income
inequality was not that bad
New York City in particular generates
more wealth than anywhere on the planet
yet we have the worst income inequality
and a lot of that comes from the
billionaires here who are not paying
taxes that know making reality so what
doesn't this take away and SAP the
incentive to join that billionaire class
just strive for that to be the next
Oprah to be the next Bloomberg doesn't
that deprive you of that initiative if
you know you're gonna be taxed and in
New York by the way place you want to
run the if you took this seventy percent
if you took the seventy percent tax rate
that she's proposing and slapped your
local taxes on it you're talking about
an eighty two point seven percent tax
for the 1% who have had tax breaks
hundreds of trillions of dollars of tax
breaks which have starved our housing
are our schools our infrastructure our
MTA we're talking about a decrepit city
that generates more wealth and it's
because these 0.1% are not paying taxes
we're not talking about they are new
businesses they're opening their
businesses and the economy the rise in
the economy is exploding taxpayer
dollars give everybody their time corey
anderson cooper challenged to his credit
cortez listen i think that it only has
ever been radicals that have changed
this country Abraham Lincoln made the
radical decision to sign the
Emancipation Proclamation Franklin
Delano Roosevelt made the radical
decision to embark on establishing
programs like Social Security that is
radical do you call yourself a radical
yeah you know if that's what radical
means call me a radical Cory yuria boy
look it's amazing you know she's been in
office exactly about 24 hours
she's comparing herself to FDR and JFK
and and Lincoln look there's a long way
to go but what she is advocating for is
a tax rate of 83% in California 84 85
percent in New York City to her close
personal friends like Michael Bloomberg
who's created tens of thousands of jobs
right because they're the ones gonna be
paying for this Michael Bloomberg I
think Michael Bloomberg goes at Donald
Trump's wedding Alexandre de conciertos
lives in my neighborhood you're talking
about Cori you live in another
youniverse she's the one who just said
that the rich the 1% should pay 70% on
top of the 8% sales to 8% so michael
byrne should pay more yeah absolutely
Bloomberg and and so what stops what
stops those billionaires from paying
more right now there's nothing that
prohibits them from paying more right
now that if they want to why can't they
watch it they're so concerned they're
taking backs of working I want you I
want you both to react to this like Jeff
Bezos does okay okay now the easy new
numbers today the the numbers of jobs
added to this economy three hundred and
twelve thousand jobs added 2.6 million
jobs added in the entire year you have
wages going up 3.2 percent these are
some record and incredible numbers are
you worried that if you move to this
type of tax system and by the way rosa
DeLauro all in connecticut she's
proposing hiking taxes up to five
percent from point nine percent to 4
percent for obamacare is this what we
need more of and might this disturb the
economic Renaissance we're in the midst
of Corey you first look it's very simple
Donald Trump has created more jobs in
the manufacturing space in two years
than Barack Obama did in two terms and
the bottom line is if you raise taxes on
people who are creating jobs they're
gonna stop creating jobs if you raise
the interest rates
they'll stop investing money they'll
stop borrowing money and that has a
trickle-down effect Donald Trump's tax
policies of cutting taxes for everyone
across the board has worked and if you
don't believe me go look at the numbers
of the unemployment rate for Hispanics
and african-americans in our country
they're at record lows because of the
job-creating
opportunities to put in place know me
keep the Hispanic numbers the
unemployment Hispanic numbers look I'm a
Latino but the Hispanic numbers are in
the at the bottom historic lows of
unemployment you have more workplace
participation among Hispanics than ever
before what's wrong with that
isn't that an economy working no it's
not an economy working witnesses right
now what would it wages are lower than
ever and you don't have benefits so yes
people are working two jobs but they're
still unable to make the rent rent is
higher than it's ever been and wages are
lower so when you don't have benefits if
you drink your art this is absolutely
true Cory
it's called economy and maybe you should
be Jeffrey Sachs because when you break
your arm and you suddenly are bankrupt
because you don't have health care that
is why when you pay for taxes you pay
into Medicare it prevents you from going
into bankruptcy so it's not just that
wages need to be higher people are
working more and they have the cost of
living is higher and then they're going
bankrupt for basic necessities like
crime is down unemployment is down this
is a wonderful thing if this took place
once the Obama economy you'd be praising
him as the greatest president since
probably Lincoln oh wait Sanders Bernie
Sanders wants to add you know 2.2
percent to the payroll tax and amongst
other things that he wants to add more I
want acquired it for a moment so you can
fight over something else I want to get
your thoughts on this these new reports
that Hillary Clinton is meeting with
possible 2020 Democrats you know because
her own campaigns went so swimmingly she
reportedly met with Kamala Harris Cory
Booker Elizabeth Warren among others
nough Miki why are Democrats coming to
kiss lose woman's ring 36 percent our
approval rating in the recent polls how
is that a plus for them if you want to
beat Donald Trump you have to have a
movement you have to have a working
people's movement I think too many
Democrats the majority of status quo
Democrats are too worried about raising
money and what does Secretary Clinton
have she has a lot of donors and she has
a lot of access to infrastructure that
they think will get them the win against
Donald Trump I am supporting Bernie
Sanders because there's a movement of
millions of working act
this across America who are ready to
fight and have been fighting for things
like medicare-for-all cancellation of
student debt and the green new deal Cory
she makes a great point there about
Sanders really did awaken a grassroots
movement if I were if I were one of
these Democratic candidates I'd probably
be beating a path to Michelle Obama's
house and becoming her best friend given
those book sales and the recent polls
about them your reaction to all these
Democrats said kissing Hillary's ring
well look I'll give you credit Bernie
Sanders had the second largest crowds of
any candidate in the last election
behind Donald Trump so he clearly had a
movement behind Russia the system was
the system was rigged against him look
the only Russians that were involved
were in the Clinton campaign when she
took five million dollars from my law
firm and gave it to a British spy to go
to the Russian and put the two put
together dossier that's your party that
did that not the Republican Party so
let's just be clear about that one more
thing hot off the line but but the
bottom line is this any candidate who's
looking for Hillary Clinton's
endorsement is going to lose she were in
a terrible campaign she had a terrible
operation in place and she lost a
campaign that every pundit thought she
should have won okay I gotta go to this
I'm gonna run out of time and I want to
show my people this be quiet just for
one second hot off the livestream
beer-drinking down to earth talk with
real American senator Elizabeth Warren
he's spending the weekend with voters in
Iowa and there's a drinking theme here
she's in an Iowa saloon tonight she said
this just minutes ago I'm not a career
politician I never thought I'd run for
public office I never thought of this
what pulls me into the fight is that I
got a chance as a kid and that chance
was because taxpayers invested in public
schools okay
who's buying this I'll start with you
know making well you know the old adage
it's it's the politician you want to
have a beer with that's why supposedly a
George W Bush won okay I guess it looks
like Sheppard where the beer was what do
you mean this boy won good like that but
beer with Corey your take I have a sworn
she's a terrible candidate she's had a
terrible launch so far she launched that
time anomalous paying attention she took
the DNA test to prove that she is no
more Native American than you know I am
and I'm not a Native American I'm proud
that fact that you know I understand
that and she doesn't get regardless of
what my cheekbones look like right my
family never told me I wasn't it lie to
me what are you talking about the bottom
line is that's what if you know anything
about Elizabeth Warren she said she was
Native American because she had high
cheekbones I gave you all these male
cheekbones let me leave it they are
great conversation